okay so it's my great pleasure to
introduce ralph
rothenberg berger from the hassel
plattner institute
at the university of potsdam in germany
i had the pleasure of
visiting him actually with him and his
advisor
at the hpf which is a very nice place uh
ralph is a phd student over there
and he works in
[Music]
complexity theory in general but he's
particularly interested in
why sat solvers are so efficient so
without further ado ralph yeah
thanks vijay um so i'm going to tell you
something about
two structural parameters that in part
already came up which are heterogeneity
and locality or as we interpreted
geometry and i'm going to present you
essentially our latest result
from soda this year and
yeah i i think i don't have to motivate
that
we have a lot of structure in industrial
set instances
what you can see here are the primal
grass
of um on the left a random case at
instance
and on the right um hardware model
checking instance
this is on the right is the instance
that also
um jordy mentioned to uh
to show that it has a power load
distribution
and what you can see here in this
graphical representation is
that it also seems to have a nice
community structure
with the communities colored in
different colors here
so stefan and jordy already mentioned a
lot of parameters
for example heterogeneity
locality low fractal dimension and
others
but the ones we are interested in
as i said heterogeneity and locality
and i'm going to start by talking a bit
about heterogeneity
and we are going to interpret it um as
jordy did
so we're going to assume that industrial
instances seem to have some
scale free structure or some kind of
power distribution
so if you have
a random case at instance without the
structure
the distribution of variable frequencies
so how many variables
appear certain number of times looks
something like this
like a poisson distribution
but in industrial instances it looks
something like this
especially it has these very long tails
and it seems to resemble a power or
distribution
um that means the fraction of variables
that appear i times is proportional to i
to the minus beta
the better is the power exponent and
this is just
some constant that is intrinsic to the
instance you are looking at
so jordy also presented
their model for generating instances
with such
distributions and well essentially you
choose n clauses at random and for each
clause you
draw k variables without repetition
but now you don't draw them uniformly at
random
but with a probability
proportional to a power law probability
distribution
and you can see below
how to do this in a discrete way so
the i boolean variable essentially has a
probability proportional to n
over i to the one over beta minus one
where better is again the power exponent
and then you negate the k variables with
probability one half to get
a random clause and
we studied this model extensively over
the last years
and we got some results
regarding the satisfiability threshold
that i
in part already talked about last week
at
the fellows talk so today i'm going to
concentrate on something else namely
on the resolution width and resolution
size of those instances
and we showed in our recent paper
using the framework of ben sassen and
richardson
how large resolution with of these
instances is so these
are lower bounds for the exponent c
of the resolution width
and to the c depending on the power
exponent
better so for
very small batters for example if you
have k
good three and their better is smaller
than 2.5
um we know that the resolution with is
actually constant and above that it
slowly increases up to being
linear with and something similar seems
to hold
for all constant values of k where the
resolution will
slowly increases and then becomes linear
so we have this intricate dependence on
the power exponent
that's very interesting that we also
like to study
with regards to satisfiability
thresholds
and as you might also know
from the same paper of ben sassen and
richardson a resolution width of w
implies a resolution size exponential
in omega w squared over n
um there's a question right that's a
point
so it says are these lower bounds or are
there matching upper bounds
there are lower bounds those are all
lower bounds
so it could be that resolution that
already is
linear um earlier than what i showed you
um because we also have this jump here
where resolution whip suddenly becomes
linear
and this is due to the formula suddenly
having
high vipertite expansion which
is essentially what you use in uh the
work of ben sassen and richardson
um but you can also show something if
you don't have high bipap expansion
and this is why we also have results um
below that point
this is a proof or this is empirically
observed
this is a proof okay yeah those are all
rigorous results
um so
uh as resolution width and resolution
size are somewhat related
and what you need to have non-trivial
lower bounds
also on the resolution size is that your
width is
at least square root n and
well you can essentially read that off
from the chart i show you
but um i i save you the trouble and i'm
going to
present it a bit more graphically
so these are essentially our results on
satisfiability and unsatisfiability
depending on power exponent and the
clause variable ratio
and now we can complete this picture a
bit
by also having results on the resolution
size
um we have that if the power exponent is
large enough
above 2k minus 2 over k minus 2
we have exponential resolution size
above 7k minus 2 over 3k minus two
we have at least super polynomial
resolution size
um and below two k minus one over k
minus one we have constant resolution
size
so there seems to be a transition going
on um
where resolution size increases with the
power or exponent
and in that area in between we still
don't know what happens
it could be that is some kind of sweet
spot where resolution size might be
polynomial
but i personally doubt that
and to have also some
some values that you can maybe interpret
more
um i give you a little table of what
where these bounds
are for different values of k and
what's important here is well below this
first
column and the second column there is
there's the gap of where we don't know
what happens
and this is usually not a large range of
parlor exponents where we don't know
anything
so this is something for future work
maybe closing this gap
and yeah so those are essentially our
results on heterogeneity
and but we also wanted to look at
locality
and usually when you look at locality
you have some kind of measure for that
for example modularity which essentially
says that
um if you have three vertices
and two of them are connected to
the third one then it's more probable
that these two
vertices are also connected um with each
other
uh and we already have or there already
are some results on modularity
and effect on um set instances
so modularity alone doesn't seem to be
a good measure because it still
may result in bad server runtimes and it
may also result in exponential
resolution size
so instead of looking at locality
and as modularity
we have a different interpretation
because we assume that we have some
underlying geometry in where our
variables and clauses live in and
locality comes from connecting
clauses to variables that are somewhat
close in this geometry
so we don't need uh need to have any
modularity we immediately get
some measure of locality by assuming an
underlying geometry
more precisely we consider a model with
the following parameters
again we have n variables m clauses
and we also assume the width of the
clauses to be
k but we can also assume some
variable weights again for example power
weights
and we assume that our variables and
clauses
have positions in some geometric space
for example
a d-dimensional taurus so ralph there is
a question
with regard to your previous results
are the width lower bounds using
expansion did you they use the
expansion um yeah
i know um so
the we have two kinds of lower bounds
one of them use bypass expansion
as the result by ben sassen and
richardson does
the other one doesn't use expansion but
essentially the properties from the
benzes and which is in framework
that you need to show a high resolution
with
that are usually implied by expansion so
you don't
have to have expansion but you only have
to have those properties and you can
show them directly
without having a high expansion
so yeah yeah we use expansion but we
don't only use expansion we can also
show something
if we don't have high expansion
okay so we assume to have this
geometric model what we do is um
we randomly distribute our
variable nodes in our geometry
then we randomly distribute our clause
nodes in our geometry
and now we want to connect each clause
to k variables
and to do so we have to consider two
things first of all
the weight of the variable and second of
all it's
distance to the clause node so
to have a measure of distances we assume
p norm with some
p which can be any natural number
or uh infinity and we also assume to
have some
temperature which controls
um how many long range edges or how many
random edges you can have
so if the temperature is high a clause
doesn't necessarily connect to
the variable with smallest distance or
the variables with smallest distances
but it might also connect to a random
variable which might be very far away
and the probability to connect a
clause to a variable or
to draw a variable is
proportional to the expression i give
you down there
so as you see it depends on the weight
of the variable
and the distance between variable and
clause and it also depends
on the temperature the temperature is
very low the
clause draws the k variables that
are um closest
um regarding the weighted distance so
the weight still plays a role there
and if the temperature is very high it
essentially only
uh draws random variables so you get
something like the uniform model
um so this is the model we consider
and what do we show the ah right
i forgot each clause connects with three
variables in this example
and we show
essentially that if the number of
clauses
is linear in the number of variables
then in this model
asymptotically almost surely there's a
very short
unsatisfiable sub formula which
essentially only consists
of k different variables and this also
holds
if the weights of the variables are
heterogeneous so if we have
these conditions which essentially say
the maximum weight shouldn't be too high
and the sum of the weights should be
linear in the number of
variables so this could also mean that
you have
a parallel distribution uh just
satisfies these conditions
and we can also have a
moderate influence of random edges so
the temperature can be
anything between zero and one
and uh well then we know our formulas
are
very trivially unsatisfiable for
constant
constant clause variable ratios
uh how do we show this result well
the idea is pretty easy uh imagine again
that we have
our geometry and we randomly distribute
our
variable notes um what we look at
are uh vulnerability diagrams of
the nodes in this geometry so
the volume diagram of this would look
something like that
so for each node you have a region and
that region essentially says
if a point falls into that region it is
closer to
this node than to any other node for
example every
all the points here in this region on
the left
are closer to this variable than
to any other variable if you would now
randomly also distribute your clause
notes
then by looking at the region the clause
falls into you can immediately say
which variable it is closest to
and if those clauses would only contain
one variable
then you would immediately know which
variable which one variable
it would contain uh just by looking at
the region it falls into
and you can generalize this idea of or
noid diagrams
also to look at
more than only one variable and this is
called an order k
volenoid diagram so other k-1
diagrams you have also regions but not
for every variable node but for every
subset of k different variables
and you can draw a diagram in a similar
way
and then if you randomly draw your
clauses
just by looking at the region the clause
falls into
you know exactly which k variables this
clause contains
and um so there's a question there are
two questions i think
one by nicola but i we can take it after
the end of your talk
the other one is relevant to your
current set of slides
the question is from sibo which says did
i understand well
that the clauses and variables on slide
12
are distributed randomly where is the
connection to the true structure of the
formula
the witch structure uh
i guess i think sybil is trying to say
with
um actually i don't know uh what do you
mean by true structure or symbol
yeah let's yeah let's take it at the end
of the talk symbol okay okay
yeah no i no no no there you are sorry
go ahead no because uh it depends on
how you distribute your your points you
know
yeah i mean it sure it does um
but we assume that they are distributed
uniformly at random
okay yeah
and to so in order to not have any edge
cases
we also assume that our geometry is a
taurus
um yeah so this is this is essential
but you can model a lot by having the
right geometry and norm
already
so when you have an industrial instance
this should have some quite some um
defined structure or
i don't know how to maybe my question
was to
to um unclear
um so essentially what we're capturing
with this model
is um locality so
if you use this model you get um
some kind of community structure or
locality
for free um
however uh
it's it's not clear how industrial
instances
actually relate to that model because
you would have to show that um you can
somehow embed
um the incidence graphs
of industrial instances into a suitable
geometry which you also have to find
first
okay maybe that's possible we don't know
and as i said there's a lot of
geometries that
are that are captured by this model
for example you can also think of having
a hyperbolic plane
which gives very good results at least
for complex networks
and so our hope was that maybe something
similar holds for
industrial set instances
okay yes thank you wrong question you
can study
what happens if we have a certain
structure but yeah
of course thank you
okay so the idea is now to look at the
order k
bonney diagrams and um the regions the
clauses fall into
and our hope is that the number of
possible regions is not too large so if
the number is
somewhat big o of n we can
essentially use a simple balls into
bin's argument
because we we randomly distribute
m clauses which is linear in the number
of variables
into o of n bins which are our regions
and the results by rap and stego tells
us that
we get a bin with a maximum load of
omega log n over log log
n uh with probability tending to one
so this would mean we would have log n
over log clock n
many clauses containing the same k
variables and in our model we choose
the signs of variables in those clauses
uniformly at random so this would mean
we have a high probability
of having unsatisfiable sub formula
so how big is the number of regions in
our geometry well we can actually
show when we show in our paper that
in some cases for example for order
three
um volanoy diagrams in two-dimensional
euclidean space
the number of regions can be larger than
n squared which is way too large to
apply the balls into bin's argument
however um the the thing is we
we don't have a worst case so we
randomly distribute our
variables uniformly at random and we can
use this fact to show
that in expectation the number of
regions is small enough
so this has already been shown before
for high dimensions for high orders
for weights and for any p norm
but to the best of our knowledge not for
all of these things together which is
what we can assume now um
so uh and this is already enough to
uh use the balls into bins argument and
to show that our formulas are
with probability tending to one
unsatisfiable
so this captures a lot of cases it
captures well we can choose arbitrary
constant k we can choose our weights
with
the constraints that i showed you before
for example power weights
we can show any p norm however
one thing is still missing here because
what about
temperature what if we allow random
edges to some extent
well if we have high temperature this
could
easily destroy our proof idea because
even if a clause
lands in a certain region it does not
necessarily contain
decay variables from that region it
might contain
a variable that's very far apart
so but for temperatures smaller than one
we can actually show that there's a
constant fraction of clauses that
behaves well
so if the clause lands in a region it
contains exactly
k variables from that region and no
variable that's further away and then
our argument with balls and the bins
still goes through
so this is essentially the idea of the
proof
um and
this was our take on geometry
or locality bio geometry
and well i'm gonna conclude now and
recap what we saw so essentially
what we showed was that heterogeneity
in terms of a power distribution at
least
doesn't seem to help much so if the
power exponent is too small
you get a constant resolution size if
it's too large you get
super polynomial resolution size
although it might still be that there's
some sweet spot in between there which
might model
cdcl runtime on industrial instances
nicely
but i actually doubt it
and if you have geometry it seems to
have too much
so it makes a formula is trivially
unsatisfiable
if you draw a number of clauses that's
linear and the number of
variables and this also holds if you
have
heterogeneous variable distributions
like a power distribution
if you have some moderate
moderately many long edges or random
edges
and it holds for many different
geometries
so for d-dimensional tauri for
d-dimensional hypercubes and also for
hyperbolic
planes um yeah
so this was our take on heterogeneity
and geometry
thank you thank you ralph thank you for
a great talk i'll go back to nicolas
question
please uh it says are you using
expansion for the
exponential lower bounds region and the
other properties
for the super polynomial lower bound
region
so you mentioned some other properties
other than expansion that you use to
improve or bounce right and is it the
case that the other pro
first of all what are those other
properties um secondly are they are you
exclusively using them for
the super polynomial lower bounds
essentially yes so um
yeah we're using these other prop
properties for super polynomial
uh lower bounds and those properties
come
from the
from the paper of benzasson and
richardson
and essentially what you need are two
properties that
you don't have
so that any any proof
needs many clauses from
your clause base to any unsatisfiability
group needs many clause from a clause
base
to be derived which um essentially
translate to you
must have um
a large unsatisfiable sub form you can't
have a small unsatisfiable sub formula
and the other property is that
you have many
[Music]
in each subset of clauses you have many
unique variables which then translates
to
large resolution width in the proof you
derive
thank you jody i think
had a comment um it says
let me read the comment all these models
of generations of random formulas are
simple ways of generating
random formulas with properties observed
in most industrial instances
it does not mean personal factors
sorry it was an answer to the previous
question
not not a question itself
i know i it's a comment yeah but but i i
think
um i agree with the heterogeneity point
in other words the heterogeneity
property that you're exploring
is indeed also absorbed in industrial
instances
but i'm not sure so much about the way
you're defining
geometry or the way you're defining
locality via geometry because
there it seems like it's an overkill
because you are embedding these two to
the k
uh unsat formulas
which are trivially unsad right so that
so therefore i think that
while it's interesting result i feel
that the geometry
is probably too strong and it has to be
somehow weakened
in order to reflect reality yeah
i mean essentially this is what we
wanted to show geometry is
too strong because you could i mean you
we want to capture locality somehow and
there are many ways to do that
and one of them is geometry and we
wanted to show no don't use geometry
that's too much
yeah and the problem with modularity as
you said at the beginning
is that you can show the existence of
formulas that have good modularity but
have very large proofs uh which was done
by
nathan mall and company so that's the
problem modularity is too weak
on its own yeah so i have to somehow
strengthen that
but i agree with the overall point you
raise here which is heterogeneity and
locality
seem to be uh two
structural parameters which have that
if you if properly defined would likely
have both
properties that was mentioned by stefan
that they satisfy the correlation model
and they are also rigorously analyzable
uh
which was what uh initially was stated
by
in stefan's first slide that ideally you
would like both of them but
it turns out that the parameters explode
so far
are either in one box or the other but
not both as yet
thank you again ralph for a great